so if you haven't noticed Marvel is a
bit popular these days uh anyway a lot
of people were introduced to these
characters and worlds through that on
inspiring thing called the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's really cool that
people in the mainstream are learning
about stuff like Captain America and his
battles of Hydra the formation of the
Avengers or all these obscure characters
like domestic-abuse man and professor
comedy cape I still remember how I got
into most this stuff as a kid I loved
spiderman x-men Batman and venom that
was about it when it came to comics I
hadn't really discovered the rest of the
big wide world of serialized shark jump
and glory we all know and love my
fascination with the medium didn't take
hold until after I played the game
Marvel Ultimate Alliance which taught me
that there are plenty of cool characters
outside of just the ones I associated
with it was my gateway to dozens of new
stories and characters in the Marvel
Universe in a world where Thanos and
helicarrier's are practically common
knowledge I think it would be fun to
take a look back at the game that showed
me these things for the first time and
see how it holds up today and maybe make
a couple of riffs about all the things
they've changed since then some people
may remember the strange practice that
game devs used back in 2006 where they
would put out really crappy versions of
games on the older consoles to
incentivize people to get the new ones
that were just coming out I still
remember how shocked I was when I found
out spider-man web of Shadows was a side
scroller on ps2 but I went with the
actual game these days if a game came
out on both generations it was the same
thing with slightly less extensive
graphics and it's barely noticeable I'm
really happy that this game is the same
way and the differences aren't
distracting it's really just graphical
improvements and more characters oh look
at those 1080p HD graphics they were
talking about on the box every time I
read the back of a videogame cover I
feel like I need to read it with a Sonic
the Hedgehog to make it bearable
sixaxis wireless controller and dynamic
gameplay - extra playable heroes oh boy
the sixaxis the thing that like three
games utilized and then gave up on
forever because motion controls are a
stupid gimmick
alright then enough background on my
experience of the game people want to
hear me complain about dorky but like
Thor having his Ultimate Universe
costume and Hammer despite this taking
place in universe 6 1/6 gonna be a lot
of greater Marvel Universe jokes in this
one because this game is essentially
just Marvel Universe RPG oh look a
review option on the main menu maybe if
I select that this video will make
itself and I won't have to do any work
oh this game has an original story about
Doctor Doom building a massive army of
villains called one of these I think
Annie prepares a plane to rule the world
pretty simple stuff but it's a story
that allows for a road trip across
everything from the comics their
missions spread all throughout reality
in space that let you see pretty much
everything this universe has to offer
you're just running around exploring
neat fictional landmarks stomping bad
guys getting a history lesson on comics
and piecing together dooms convoluted
plan it's simple but effective not every
superhero game needs to have a complex
Arkham plutt it just needs to not lie to
your face about the characters or be
completely incomprehensible and stupid
right off the bat I'd like to recommend
this game to anyone who likes RPGs and
wants to know more about comics all the
numerous characters you need on your
journey and places you go could inspire
you to want to read up on a specific
location or person this game was my
introduction to a lot of these
characters and my perceptions of them
were shaped a lot by its take on them a
lot of why I love Marvel can be
attributed to this game teaching me so
much about it as a kid it's an amazing
journey through one of my favorite
realms of fiction now on to bitching
about everything god this camera angle
sucks I hate this sort of top down but
slanted in an angle view it's like this
game was developed by the director of
Thor either put the camera behind me or
on top of me but don't give up halfway
through deciding well I guess it was the
best they could do considering top-down
views are awful at showing care
and putting the camera behind the player
would make it difficult to navigate the
huge areas with all these characters
running around at once with a big single
screen multiplayer game you need to be
able to see as much as possible I
suppose
hello I'm very glad you could join the
team so the opening cutscene establishes
a pretty cool set of characters to play
ass but when you come to the shield logo
things on the ground you can switch them
out for anyone from this list of
badasses I've heard that on the ps3
version they have more characters than
the ps2 oh my god they have Moon Knight
yeah this guy's awesome and Colossus -
sweet Christmas
well now I'm at a loss I don't know who
to have on my team most of the time
because there's so many great characters
here hmm alright this works I'm the most
powerful force in the universe ooh
gameplay you hit X to do the punches in
circle to do a charged attack yes I say
circle instead of oh shut up Square is a
grab attack in triangle jumps wait what
if I'm playing a Spider Man oh hey look
I'm doing it mom doing it wow he really
takes off look at him go would you
believe this has way better web swinging
and friend or foe because you see if you
try to swing up the side of the Empire
State Building with a stopwatch to
assess the speed of a sentence Ness you
travel with it you'd be shocked to learn
every character has a list of powers you
can level up so they can do more comic
book II stuff you press one of these
stupid trigger buttons and then one of
the face buttons to do something cool
while playing this I would occasionally
forget about this entirely and just
hammer X until everything died usually
your team is pretty overpowered because
you come across enemies one at a time
and curb stomp them as a gang even some
of the bosses just get destroyed by the
four of you it's a great bonding
experience but you start to get a little
bored knowing that nothing can stand in
your way for the first half of the game
then the later missions get somewhat
difficult though so you'll just have to
power through it until then or overpower
through it rather
Black Widow I feel we've known each
other long enough that I can ask you are
you putting on weight now this game was
actually my first exposure to Deadpool I
had no idea who that was until I played
this game the week it came out ah how
I'd missed you Montpetit Shepard let us
run away and live a carefree life
someplace exotic like Pittsburgh his
voice sounds a little weird in this game
because if I'm not mistaken this is the
first time the character had been voiced
in anything and those weird yellow text
bubbles give the impression that his
voice would be a little rough I don't
know it works for the time being that
there wasn't an official voice by then
Nolan North hadn't done his version yet
so this is what people just accept it as
the voice I even remember watching
YouTube parodies as a kid where they
tried to mimic this one the voice acting
is generally solid for most characters
and a lot of these are the voices I hear
when I'm reading the comics especially
Black Bolt they really nailed it and
it's fun that some of the voices were
done by fans that sent in auditions in
2006
I wish game company still did stuff like
that you already know who I'd love to
play there's something strange about
comparing the way these characters were
11 years ago to now because the Marvel
Cinematic Universe of all of them so
much in that time span the x-men and
Fantastic Four aren't social pariahs
that have their existence constantly
threatened or denied iron man's kind of
humble and doesn't make jokes every two
seconds because they started writing his
character to mimic Robert Downey jr.
instead of the other way around there I
said it
spider-man isn't a clumsy fanboy and
actually sees the Avengers as equals
while also rightfully thinking some of
them are full of crap we still see Nick
Fury senior instead of his son Samuel L
fury who is an unlockable costume Jarvis
and vision are two separate people that
exists at the same time why is Bruce
Banner in this game but they don't even
so much as say the word Hulk
what a waste Hulk needs some positive
press that gives me an idea
hey wait a minute I looked it up and it
says the Hulk is only in the Xbox
version oh what the hell is it because
they had a green color scheme and I
can't get any of the DLC anymore on PSN
dammit fine here now I have it on the
ps4 where's my venom
since I ended up getting all three
versions of the game I gotta say the
newest gen looks the best
this one has good textures and the
colors aren't all faded and washed out
it actually looks Pleasant the boss
fights range from fighting just a single
random Marvel villain unceremoniously or
a fight at the end of a level of a huge
monster or giant robot or something
something I like about the smaller
bosses is that they have special
dialogue if you play as a character
associated with them so Mysterio doesn't
say much to you if you're just any
random character but if you play a
Spider Man he talks to him directly and
it's fully voice acted it was my bag of
cheesy puffs okay TJ Miller I have a
suspicion that this is a Peter Parker
character model they just ended up using
four weasel instead man weasel sure look
different back then
here's him now feel old yet so anyway
the big boss fights are pretty inventive
you have to basically do a mini puzzle
to defeat each boss which is preferable
to just hammering a single button at
them until they die although sadly this
game did come out in an era when
QuickTime events were being used as a
crutch to replace strategy so most them
require playing Simon Says to win a
problem specific to the ps3 copies is
that they decide to use good old motion
controls and it takes three tries to
figure out what the hell the game is
telling you to do why on earth was there
a point in time where someone thought
this wasn't as good as this the area is
you travelin in this game range from
being really exciting to sort of dull
locations include different realms near
Asgard and evil circus hell the bottom
of the ocean space like four different
times a creepy old Asian Castle a creepy
old European castle and steel corridors
I feel like this game could have really
benefited from using the Marvel
Universe's focal point
NYC maybe a little overused in gaming
but it's so important to so many of
these characters 90% of them live there
or are from there it would be nice to
get some scenery that isn't a cramped
hallway for once some of the missions
start to fade together in your head
because it's just metal hallways with
varying degrees of lighting here's a
dimly lit one here's a bright one here's
one with medium lighting Stagg
and my least-favorite mission has to be
when they go to Atlantis there's nothing
creative about it it's just Atlantis
picture Atlantis in your head that's
what it looks like in the game go even
likes Namor by the way like is is there
a huge fan base for Namor that I'm
unaware of all right right sure sure
okay sure
right sure yeah yes right okay Wesley
Snipes were you hiding from the tax
collectors in a skill crane machine get
on out here buddy we got bad guys to
fight now if you're turned off by the
idea of going on this quest with four
characters instead of just your favorite
their unlockable missions designed for
every individual hero where you learn a
bit of their backstory then you go on a
solo rampage and fight a boss that isn't
in the main game it's a really neat set
of side missions or if that's not enough
you can just get rid of your squad yep
just kick them all out and go do the
epic mission on your own which is
actually pretty funny I just can't
imagine this enormous quest to save the
universe being done by just the thing or
what if it's just like Luke Cage versus
the Marvel Universe or what about Iceman
interacting with this a myriad of
characters and going to defeat Doctor
Doom single-handedly
[Music]
hey Iceman good to see you buddy hey I
heard that you're gay now I know it's
crazy right I mean you think you know a
guy but hey the heart wants what the
heart wants right it must be difficult
being discriminated against for being a
mutant in addition to being gay but hey
you're not the first game you maybe you
could go visit that alternate universe
where Wolverine and Hercules are a
couple they seem like nice boats hey
Bobby I'm just really proud of you for
being so proud okay that's really
awesome of you hey everyone did you know
Iceman is really gay like really
actually gay hey come on man it's all
right no need to be shy we're all
friends here yeah he's totally gay you
guys all those chicks he dated were just
beards he ever consider hooking up with
mystique again since she can just be a
guy in fact Claremont wanted her to be
night crawlers dad but the comics code
Authority decided every act of the game
story has a hub area with all kinds of
side characters walking around like
stark tower where he can hang out in an
office or go on Iron Man's lab oh look
it's Jarvis back before you is rewritten
to be cortana wow this place is super
busy that's a lot of scientists walking
around doing nothing my favorite of the
hub areas is the sanctum sanctorum dr.
Strangelove's house is really cozy and I
would totally live here I would rather
die than spend an eternity here take
friends tell Scott I love him and tell
Logan I love him okay so the final
mission is built up throughout the game
as this assault on dooms castle you keep
recruiting super people so you can go
invade this small European country and
assault the home of its peaceful
benevolent ruler you stick it to the bad
guys and also smack around a couple of
good guys too for fun and you say the
world thought it being about a boom but
then you get this monologue from The
Watcher about how much of a failure you
are if you didn't do this long list of
side objectives so in order to get the
good ending you have to stop the super
soldiers from destroying a research
terminal find valkyrie sword find this
old lady's ring in a box in the snow
tell weasel had a flirt with Ben Grimm
successfully stopped Galactus from
eating the scrolls save the queen of the
Shiar Empire performed brain surgery on
the leader to steal as gamma power
sacrificed Jean Grey in a satanic ritual
saved Mike Pence and murder world by
Tony Stark a high-class escort save
Namor from dying due to civil unrest
embarrass Iceman when you're just trying
to be nice and punch yourself well
that's one way to encourage replay value
tell the player they're an idiot for not
doing all the side quests now I'm sure
as most Marvel fans know it's not the
same as it was you can debate on the
quality of it all now whether it's
gotten better or worse is for you to
decide but either way it's not how it
was 11 years ago it may never be that
way again and that's part of the beauty
of such a real and thriving universe of
fiction it's ever-evolving and
perpetually growing and shrinking
there's been a lot of controversy lately
about the path Marvel has taken and
while some changes are a lot of fun
others make you just wish you go back a
decade when it was all simpler this game
is a time capsule of the Marvel Universe
as it was before everything got so
political
before everything started being afraid
to have fun for all the controversies
and opinions and writer egos bled into
our place of escapism this isn't the
first time it's been like this and it
certainly won't be the last this
universe is a million little
flash-in-the-pan stories all happening
at once and it's easy to lose track of
it all but there's something to love
about all of it even the bad stuff
keeping the stupid stuff all these
little moments start to feel like drops
of rain and a storm and I know a lot of
people do their best to collect them all
before they fade from memory this simple
little game about stopping Doctor Doom
in itself feels like a collection of
those moments like a greatest hits album
like a TV marathon of a long cancelled
show you loved from childhood this game
is a beautiful little relic of one
moment in time in a medium that will
persist long after any of us do this is
a part of the history and I'll always
remember how much it taught me about
this world in these people how it helped
me fall in love with this impossible
place where anything can happen
so as much as it has its flaws like any
game this video is my love letter to a
love letter to the Marvel Universe they
don't make them like that anymore
yeah we're a guy with ice power is that
come on let's give a round of applause
for the guy he's demonstrated a lot of
bravery by coming out I'm proud of my
gay friend Patti ever on I hope you
liked the review this month I was hoping
to get it out a little bit sooner but as
I said before this one was going to and
did take a long time to edit but I'm
really happy with how it came out oh boy
this is a lot harder than I thought it
would be I keep trying not to casually
swear because it's the new YouTube but
anyway I'm a lot of great people help me
with this review I had a Joey the artist
on Twitter helped with some custom art
the line of characters did the custom
avatar for the for the reviews that will
be popping up now as well as some
special text for it for the spider-man
segment scrubs animate did the source
filmmaker portion of the review and he
put a lot of work into it he spent weeks
and weeks putting it together and
polishing every detail and really
ironing out everything he did a great
job I definitely want to work with all
of those guys again in the future they
did some awesome work and I'm really
lucky to have them I also want to thank
all of the patrons who patronized me
over the past few weeks since I set it
up I really appreciate all of them and
as promised to all of them are getting
their names in the video a shout out
from from yours truly I love all of you
guys you're fantastic people and thanks
for everything in addition to this I
want to talk about a promotion I'm
running 40 blocks it's a t-shirt service
that sends your shirts in the mail they
contacted me asking if maybe I could you
know take a look at one of their
products and give you guys my thoughts
on it maybe give you a code so you can
go check it out yourself I honestly have
no idea what's in them I've held off for
several days from opening this just so I
could get it
whoa that's awesome that's super cool I
love it
tea blocks is a unique t-shirt based
subscription service that delivers one
t-shirt to your house every month
licensed characters from Marvel Disney
and HBO Naruto and a whole bunch of
other ones so it's not very expensive to
begin with but you can actually get a
10% discount if you put in this special
code
Godzilla tbx I'm sure I've edited it
right here later go ahead and type that
in and get yourself a discount and go
get some cool t-shirts you can get a
cool t-shirt in the mail and then you
can take a selfie with it and then you
can send the selfie to me on Twitter and
be like hey Xavier check out the cool
t-shirt I got I'll be like dude that's
cool check out the cool t-shirt I got
and we can have like a contest to see
you gots the cooler t-shirt you know if
you're looking for some more videos you
watch this one or this one
you can also give this a shot maybe this
is a little bit of a try to knows you
know you know give it a chance might not
regret it might be pretty cool ok see
you around folks I guess I don't know
has it been 20 seconds yet